RAYMOND ARROYO.
>> Greg: HAPPY THURSDAY,
EVERYONE.
I'M SO EXCITED.
BECAUSE IT'S TIME FOR --
♪♪
YES, WELCOME TO "HUG YOUR THUG"
WHERE VICTIMS AND VICTIMIZERS
COME TOGETHER TO SEE WHO THE WHO
CRIMINAL IS.
I'M YOUR HOST, JOY BEHAR.
LET'S ADDRESS A CANDIDATE FOR
CITY COUNCIL TIFFANY CABAN,
WANTS VICTIMS OF VIOLENT CRIMES
TO WORK WITH THEIR ATTACKERS IN
THE NAME OF RESTORATIVE JUSTICE.
IF YOU SEE JUSTICE IN FRONT OF
CRIMINAL, YOU KNOW YOU'RE
GETTING NONSENSE.
LEGIT JUSTICE REQUIRES LAW AND
ORDER, SOMETHING LEFTIES HATE
MORE THAN SOAP AND WATER.
CABAN CALLS IT A PUBLIC SAFETY
PLAN.
FOR WHOM EXACTLY?
BRINGING THE VICTIM WITH THE
PERP THAT BEATS HER?
THIS IS THE WORLD'S WEIRD'S
DATING APP.
HOW DID YOU TWO LOVES ONES MEET?
HE PISTOL WHIPPED ME UNDER A
BRIDGE IN CENTRAL PARK AND STOLE
MY PURSE.
CABAN CALLS IT'S A PUBLIC SAFETY
PLAN.
IT'S ABOUT AS SAFE AS DIALLING
WITH THE TALIBAN AND ASKING FOR
KOSHER OPTIONS.
IT'S ABOUT AS SAFE AS WEARING A
DOUGHNUT SUIT AROUND BRIAN
STELTZER, THIS ISMENT TO STRIP
COPS AND COURTS OF AUTHORITY.
HERE'S PART TESTIFY THE
PROPOSAL.
EXAMPLE OF USE.
A PERSON IS BEAT UP, SUFFERS A
BROKEN RIB AND ROBBED OF HIS
WALLET.
HIS NEEDS ARE HEARD AND AFFIRMED
AND WORKS WITH TRAINED STAFF TO
DEVELOP A SERVICES AND HEALING
PLAN.
FIRST OF ALL, THANKS FOR
ASSUMING THE GENDER OF THE CRIME
VICTIM.
SHOULDN'T IT BE THEIR WALLET?
I WOULD ONLY HOPE THE VICTIM
FILLING OUT A PRONOUNCE WORK
SHEET.
KEEPS GOING.
WHEN HE'S READY, HE PARTICIPATES
IN RESTORATIVE JUSTICE CIRCLES
WITH THE PERSON THAT HARMED THEM
AND THEIR RESPECTIVE SUPPORT
SYSTEMS.
HE ASKS QUESTIONS ABOUT GET
ANSWERS AND DEVELOPS A PLAN.
I'M SUPPOSED TO DEVELOP AN
ACCOUNT ABILITY CONSEQUENCES
PLANS WITH THE LOW LIFE THAT
FLOGGED ME WITH A CAR ANTENNA,
STOLE MY I PAD?
WHAT DO YOU WANT ME TO DO NEXT?
HELP HIM WITH HIS TAXES?
WORK ON HIS TO-DO LIST?
IF I WAS MUGGED AND BEATEN, MY
FIRST QUESTION IS WHY AREN'T YOU
IN PRISON RIGHT NOW, YOU
[BLEEP].
BUT INSTEAD, HERE YOU MUST WORK
OUT THE THUG'S ISSUES.
ISN'T IT YOUR FAULT FOR HAVING
THAT MONEY THAT HE WANTED?
HE WAS JUST TAKING FROM ONE AND
GIVING IT TO ANOTHER YOU
OPPRESSOR.
SORRY, THE ONLY A RESTORATIVE
CIRCLE THAT I WANT TO SEE IS
THAT PERP ENCIRCLED BY HIS
VICTIMS AND RESTORE AGO BEATING
ON HIS ASS.
INSTEAD OF PUTTING HIM IN
PRISON, WE MAKE THE VICTIMS HIS
SOCIAL WORKER.
HOW WOULD THIS WORK OUT?
>> SO I'M YOUR THERAPIST TODAY
AND I'M SUPPOSED TO ASK YOU HOW
YOU FEEL.
>> OKAY, I GUESS.
KIND OF TIRED.
HEY, I KNOW YOU.
>> YES, YOU MUGGED ME 30 MINUTES
AGO IN CENTRAL PARK.
TOOK MY WALLET AND BROKE MY EYE
SOCKET AND CRACKED THREE RIBS.
>> I KNOW.
MY HAND STILL HURTS FROM
PUNCHING YOU.
>> I'M SORRY ABOUT THAT.
MY FACIAL BONES ARE VERY POINTY,
ESPECIALLY THE ONES YOU CRACKED.
>> IT'S OKAY.
I FORGIVE YOU.
BY THE WAY, YOU HAVE ANY MORE
MONEY?
>> NO.
YOU TOOK IT OFF.
I'M HERE TO FIND A SOLUTION FOR
YOUR PUNISHMENT.
>> PUNISH MEANT?
>> SORRY.
RESTORATIVE HEALING.
HOW DO YOU THINK WE SHOULD DEAL
WITH YOU MUGGING ME?
>> I STILL HAVE HEADACHES FROM
THE HIGH PITCH SCREAMING YOU
WERE DOING WHEN I PUNCHED YOUR
EYE SOCKET.
>> SORRY ABOUT THAT.
>> ALL RIGHT.
I GUESS I'LL SEE YOU IN THE
PARK.
MAKE SURE YOU HAVE MONEY NEXT
TIME.
>> SOUNDS GOOD.
>> OKAY.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: SO THE PEOPLE
PRETENTING TO FIGHT FOR VICTIMS
ARE DESTROYING THEIR RIGHTS AND
RUINING THE LIVES FOR EVERYONE
EXCEPT THE RICH THAT WILL ALWAYS
REMAIN UNAFFECTED.
SOMEHOW I SENSE THIS WILL NOT
LEAD THE PRISON TIME, WHICH IS
THE REAL AGENDA.
PEOPLE LIKE THIS NUT BAG BELIEVE
WE SHOULDN'T HAVE A CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM.
THAT NO ONE SHOULD BE ARRESTED
OR INCARCERATED.
THEY SEE CRIME, VIOLENT CRIME AS
BASICALLY A MISUNDERSTANDING.
DRIVEN BY POVERTY, LACK OF
EDUCATION AND RACISM.
FOR THESE CRACK POTS, THE REAL
VICTIMS OF CRIME ARE THE
CRIMINALS, THE PEOPLE THAT THEY
BEAT UP ARE JUST INSTRUMENTS OF
THEIR ATTACKER'S PERSECUTION AND
PROBABLY DESERVED TO BE MUGGED
BECAUSE THEY HAVE JOBS OR
SOMETHING.
ACCORDING TO THE "NEW YORK
POST," DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
DECLINED TO PROSECUTE ACCUSED
FELONS AT TWICE THE RATE OF 2019
LETTING MORE THAN 6,500 SUSPECTS
OFF THE HOOK.
17%.
THAT IS NOT A CRIME, WHAT IS?
THAT'S ONE WAY TO CLEAR THE
DOCKET.
YOU CAN ALSO REDUCE BURGLARIES
BY LEAVING YOUR MONEY OUTSIDE
WITH A SIGN THAT SAYS COME AND
GET IT.
MEANWHILE, A SERIAL PERVERT
MEANING A REPEAT PERVERT, NOT
SOMEONE WHO HAS SEX WITH A BOX
OF FROSTED FLAKES -- TRUST ME,
THEY'RE NOT THAT GREAT!
[LAUGHTER]
YEAH, HE'S BEEN REPEATEDLY
EXPOSING HIMSELF TO KIDS.
HE KEEPS GETTING RELEASED FROM
JAIL THANKS TO NEW YORK'S LACKS
BAIL REFORM.
EACH TIME HE'S ARRESTED, HE'S
OUT IN A FLASH.
[LAUGHTER]
THE SCUM HAS EXPOSED HIMSELF
FIVE TIMES SINCE THE END OF
APRIL.
THIS GUY SPENDS SO MUCH TIME
WITH HIS PANTS DOWN IN BROAD
DAYLIGHT HE HAS TO PUT SUNSCREEN
ON HIS JUNK.
FIVE TIMES HE'S DONE THIS.
FOUR MORE TIMES THAN JEFFERY
TUBIN.
TWO MORE EXPOSURES AND HE GETS
HIS OWN SHOW ON CNN.
[LAUGHTER]
ACCORDING TO THE "NEW YORK
POST," THIS FLASHING FREAK KEEPS
GETTING SPRUNG BECAUSE JUDGES
ARE LARGELY BARRED FROM IMPOSING
BAIL ON THE MISDEMEANOR CHARGES.
I BET THE JUDGES MIGHT FEEL
DIFFERENTLY IF IT WAS ON THEIR
STREET.
WHERE IS THE MEDIA IN THIS?
THE MAJOR NEWS NETWORKS HAVE
SPENT LESS THAN AN HOUR COVERING
THE CRIME WAVES IN 15 DEMOCRATIC
CONSTITUENTS.
WHAT HAPPENED TO IF IT BLEEDS IT
LEAVES?
NOW IT'S MORE LIKE IF THE VICTIM
IS A GONER, IT'S A YAWNER.
WHY IS THAT.
>> THE MEDIA SHARES THE BLAME IF
THEY ACCURATELY COVERED CRIME
THEY WOULD EXPOSE THEIR OWN
CULPABILITY.
THEY PUSH TO DEFUNDING THE CONS,
DEMONIZING POLICE AND DEFENDED
THE RIOTS.
THEY'RE ALL GOING TO GO IN ON
JANUARY 6, PRETENDING TO CARE
ABOUT THE OFFICERS AND THOSE
VICTIMS.
AND THROW EVERYONE ELSE IN
PRISON.
NO RESTORATIVE JUSTICE NEEDED.
[APPLAUSE]
WELCOME, TONIGHT'S GUEST, SHE
HOSTS A SHOW AFTER THIS ONE.
IF HER RATINGS SUFFER, IT'S HER
FAULT.
HOST OF FOX NEWS AT NIGHT,
SHANNON BREAM.
HE'S AN EXPERT ON FINANCES AND
SMOLDERING GLANCES.
FORMER DIRECTOR OF THE NATIONAL
ECONOMIC COUNCIL AND HOST OF FOX
BUSINESS, LARRY KUDLOW.
THE ONLY TIME HE HEARS NICE SET
IS WHEN HE SELLS ENCYCLOPEDIAS.
SHE'S LIKE MY GRANDMOTHER'S
MEATLOAF.
ONLY TOLLERING WHEN COVERED IN
GRAVY.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR, KAT TIMPF.
SHANNON, GOOD TO SEE YOU.
PEOPLE KEEP ASKING ME IF YOU'RE
REALLY EVIL OR NOT.
>> THEY ASK ME.
THEY'RE LIKE WHAT IS GREG'S
OBSESSION WITH YOU AND YOU'RE
EVILNESS?
BUT I SAY I SPEAK FOR MYSELF.
CLEARLY PEOPLE CAN SEE THE
DARKER SIDE THAT I AT THE TIME
AROUND WITH ME.
>> Greg: YOU'RE AN AWFUL EVIL
GENIUS.
IF YOU WERE THE VICTIM OF A
VIOLENT CRIME, WOULD YOU WANT TO
WORK WITH THE PERSON THAT HARMED
YOU?
>> IF YOU HAVE EVER BEEN THAT
VICTIM OR SOMEBODY YOU LOVE, YOU
KNOW THE THOUGHT OF GOING TO
COURT AND SEE THE PERSON IN THE
COURTROOM, IT'S EXCRUCIATING.
EVEN IF YOU WANT TO BE BE PART
OF PROSECUTING SOMEBODY.
I THINK THAT THAT IS ASKING A
LOT OF VICTIMS.
I DON'T KNOW WHY WE WOULD GIVE
DEFERENCE TO THE PERSON THAT
COMMITTED THE CRIME.
WHY ARE WE WORRIED ABOUT THEIR
FEELINGS AND MAKING SURE THIS
WORKS FOR EVERYBODY?
IF I CAN TAKE THEIR PUNISHMENT
BY SITTING ACROSS FROM THEM,
SURE.
>> I'M IN
>> Greg: YOU'RE RIGHT.
I WOULD MAKE IT PHYSICALLY
PAINFUL AND SLOW.
YOU RAISED A GOOD QUESTION TO
LARRY.
WHAT IS IT ABOUT CRIMINALS THAT
IS SO APPEALING TO THE LEFT?
ALL THE STORIES WERE CONNECTED
BY THE ONE THING.
DIMINISHING OF THE VICTIM AND A
PREFERENCE FOR THOSE THAT
VICTIMIZE.
>> IT'S INEXPLAINABLE.
THIS IS WOKE GONE WILD.
>> Greg: A DVD.
NOBODY BUYS DVDs ANYMORE.
THAT'S A FOX NATION SPECIAL.
>> NOTHING HAPPENS.
IT'S WOKE GONE WILD.
YOU DON'T SEE ANYTHING.
>> IT'S THE BEAUTY.
COVERS EVERY THING IMAGINABLE.
>> DEFUND THE COPS, DEFUND THE
POLICE, NOT ENOUGH.
NO BAIL?
NOT ENOUGH.
LET THEM OUT EVERY TIME?
NOW WE HAVE TO SIT WITH THEM.
NOT IN A COURTROOM BUT
PRESUMABLY ACROSS THE TABLE.
SOCIAL WORKERS, GOOD.
THERAPISTS GOOD.
POLICE NOT GOOD.
I THINK THIS WHOLE LEFTIST
CULTURE OF WOKE, EVERY TIME YOU
THINK THEY'VE GONE TOO FAR, THEY
GO FURTHER.
IT'S A MOCKERY.
THEY'RE BEING LAUGHED AT.
THE TIDE IS TURNING BECAUSE THIS
STUFF IS SO AWFUL.
THE WOKE CROWD IS LIKE A STOCK
LOOKING FOR A BOTTOM AND THEY
CANNOT FIND ONE.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: SPEAKING OF LOOKING FOR
A BOTTOM, JIMMY, I FEEL LIKE WE
NEED NEW PRISONS LIKE YOU NEED A
NEW WARDROBE.
>> OH, I HAVE A THEORY.
CAN I THROW THIS OUT AT YOU?
I HAVE A THEORY THAT YOU LOVE MY
FASHION BUT YOU'RE JEALOUS
BECAUSE IT DOESN'T COME IN KID
SIZES.
[LAUGHTER]
I OWED HIM ONE.
>> THAT WAS GOOD.
>> Greg: GLAD YOU CAME LOCKED
AND LOADED.
YOU KNEW I WAS GOING TO SAY
SOMETHING.
>> I DID.
>> Greg: ESPECIALLY WITH THOSE
BOOTS.
>> HERE'S THE PROBLEM IN
AMERICA.
WE DON'T HAVE A CRIME PROBLEM.
WE HAVE A STUPID PROBLEM.
STUPID PEOPLE GOT ELECTED AND
CONVINCED OTHER STUPID PEOPLE
THAT THE COPS WERE MORE OF A
THREAT THAN THE CRIMINALS.
AN WHEN YOU BUT IT WITH RACE,
IT'S AN ISSUE OF RIGHT OR WRONG.
WOKE POLITICS OFTEN TIME MAKE
YOU OVERLIGHT RIGHT OR WRONG.
IT'S GOTTEN US IN A BAD PLACE IN
NEW YORK.
WE HAVE THE FAMOUS WALKING
TOURS.
THEY'RE NOW CALLED RUNNING
YOU MIGHT GET MUGGED.
WRAP IT UP FAST.
WE'RE GOING TO SEE THE STATUE.
>> Greg: YOU COME UP WITH THAT
JOKE IN THE TANNING BED?
>> IT'S GOING TO BE A CHIPPY
SHOW.
THAT'S WHY HE'S THE KING OF LATE
NIGHT.
>> IT'S A SERVE TANNER.
>> Greg: I DON'T KNOW WHAT
IS.
>> YEAH.
>> Greg: KAT, THIS IS A TINY
POINT BUT I'M WONDERING IF YOU
CAUGHT THIS.
WHEN THEY HAD THAT EXAMPLE OF
THE CRIMINAL OR THE CRIME VICTIM
IN HER PLAN, THEY MADE IT A MALE
VICTIM.
I FELT LIKE BECAUSE IF THEY USED
A FEMALE VICTIM TO A VIOLENT
CRIME AND HAVING HER SIT WITH A
THUG, THEY WOULD HAVE BEEN
LAUGHED OUT OF THE ROOM.
THAT IS THE ONE THING THAT THEY
JUST SHIED AWAY FROM.
COULD YOU IMAGINE ANYBODY
FORCING A WOMAN TO SIT DOWN WITH
HER RAPIST OR SOMEBODY THAT BEAT
HER UP?
>> NO, BUT THIS WOULD.
THE CRAZIEST THINGS, THE LEFT
WAS OBSESSED WITH NO BLAMING THE
VICTIM.
EVERYTHING WAS BLAMING THE
IF YOU OFFERED ADVICE FOR HOW
WOMEN STAYED SAFE, THEN YOU'RE
BLAMING THEM IF THEY DON'T DO
THAT.
IF SOMEBODY BAD HAPPENS TO
THEM -- THIS IS LITERALLY VICTIM
BLAMING AS A POLICY.
THEY'RE SAYING IF YOU MEET WITH
THIS TEAM, YOU'LL KNOW WHAT TO
SAY.
IF YOU SAID OTHER THINGS, YOU
WOULDN'T HAVE GOTTEN BEATEN WITH
A TIRE IRON.
OR IF YOU DO, THEY STILL GOT
THROUGH THE COURT SYSTEM AND
THEY'RE BLAMING THE VICTIM FOR
THE PUNISHMENT.
THIS PERSON HAD TO GO TO PRY
ZONE AND SUFFER BECAUSE YOU
WOULDN'T SIT DOWN WITH THEM.
IT'S LIKE THEY'RE BLAMING DOUBLE
IN TERMS OF A POLICY.
>> Greg: YEAH, ALSO THE CRIMINAL
GETS TO SHOW UP WITH HIS SIDE.
SO YOU'RE INTIMIDATED.
NOT ONLY IS THE CRIMINAL GOING
TO KNOW MORE ABOUT YOU, YOU KNOW
WHAT THE THIS REMINDS ME OF?
OF CERTAIN BACKWARD COUNTRIES
THAT FORCE THE RAPIST AND THE
VICTIM TO MARRY.
NOW YOU HAVE TO MARRY.
AS IF THAT IS CONSIDERED A
PUNISHMENT.
>> I THOUGHT AFGHANISTAN WAS THE
B BLOCK.
>> Greg: WAS IT AFGHANISTAN?
I CAN'T REMEMBER.
>> THIS WOMAN, SHE WILL BE A
NATURAL ON THE CITY COUNCIL.
THEY'RE ALL CRAZY PEOPLE.
ALL SOCIALISTS AND HAVE ALL OF
THESE WEIRD IDEAS.
ANOTHER WEIRD IDEA.
I JUST GOT TO INJECT THIS.
TODAY THE CITY FATHERS, THE
EDUCATION DEPARTMENT BACKED BY
THE TEACHER'S UNION HAS DECIDED
THERE'S NO MORE HONOR ROLL IN
SCHOOLS.
I'M SURE YOU WERE ON THE HONOR
ROLL WHEN YOU WERE IN K-12
SOMEPLACE.
ONE YEAR.
ONE SEMESTER.
>> HE WAS ON THE A LIST.
>> Greg: I MUST HAVE BEEN.
I DON'T REMEMBER.
>> EVERYONE GETS A TROPHY FOR
SHOWING UP TO SCHOOL.
THERE'S NO HONOR ROLL, NO MERIT,
NO MOTIVATION, NO INCENTIVE.
THE TEACHERS ARE RUINING THE
CITY JUST LIKE THESE CRAZY
SOCIALISTS ARE RUINING THE CITY.
CRIME AND EDUCATION IS THE HEART
HOFF THE CITY AND THEY'RE
THROWING IT AWAY.
>> IT'S NOT JUST HERE.
WE COVERED LAST NIGHT IN
SAN FRANCISCO, THEY'RE PAYING
PEOPLE ON A PILOT PROGRAM NOT TO
SHOOT OTHER PEOPLE.
THEY'RE ALSO IN CALIFORNIA
TALKING ABOUT PAYING PEOPLE NOT
TO DO DRUGS.
EVERY TIME YOU SHOW UP AND YOU
DON'T GET A POSITIVE TEST, THEY
PUT MONEY ON A CARD FOR YOU.
WE'RE PAYING PEOPLE NOT TO SHOT
PEOPLE AND PAYING PEOPLE NOT TO
SHOT DRUGS.
>> Greg: ONE NOTE, THAT IS NOT
OUT THERE AS IT SOUNDS.
IN NEW YORK WE'RE PAYING METS
FANS NOT TO SHOOT THEMSELVES.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: THERE YOU GO.
>> NO HONOR ROLL.
>> Greg: BY THE WAY, IF YOU
TRIED TO FIND ANY RESEARCH ON
HOW TO REHABILITATE A VIOLENT
FELON, GOOD LUCK.
IT'S A 90% RECIDIVISM RATE,
WHICH MEANS YOU CAN'T BE DONE,
WHICH MEANS YOU NEED PRISONS,